with Invercargill City Council a few
years ago they've introduced something
called the sinking lid and the sinking
lid means that as establishments bring
down the amount of gaming machines or
the amount of licenses that have been
issued we also bring down a lid on the
amount that we issue so currently if you
have a gambling establishment like
players is a great example they own six
licenses now they don't have any
machines there but when you stop using
your machine do you have up to six
months to sell it on to another
establishment so in this case if they
don't sell those on then we will count
them out we will not allow those six
more machines to come in so with the
sinking lid you're always bringing your
number down so as machines are stopped
being used and and the licenses are
continuing to dissipate then we bring
the amount of machines allowed within
the city to lower the other major change
we're doing is we've asked that any new
establishments that do get any new
licenses that are issued or any new
establishments that set up must be done
within this central business district
area so we have created a map that you
can see on the policy that will give you
an idea of where they should be and that
is just so that gambling isn't the main
function of what that establishment
would be doing and there are other
activities available because review
gambling as an active activity it's not
something that you should be going and
doing all day it's something that you
should have other things you're doing or
maybe it's something you stopped in at a
club and you're having your drink and
you want to put some money in the pokies
as more of a recreational activity
rather than a habitual activity with the
gambling policy the thing that people
are sometimes confused by or we don't
have a lot of power we're basically re
iterating what's in the gambling act so
a lot of the things in it like how much
light there needs to be having a clock
available where the placement of an ATM
is those are all regulated by central
government all we do is over see that
those things are being done when our
inspectors are out if anyone wants to
put in a submission they're more than
welcome to we're accepting submissions
up until July twentieth
you